hello my name is chase Guthrie I'm an
application engineer with moss factory
out of Chicago today we're going to be
covering the hospital control all the
features and functionality available to
you as when you first approach your
machine you're gonna need to turn it on
to start with if you notice on the front
of the machine it's got a power on and
power off button they're pretty
self-explanatory how Iran is going to
cycle the power and then the machine is
going to boot up the computer inside the
control once the computer has booted up
the machine is ready for us to start
manipulating it a little bit so it has a
startup checklist that it will come up
on the front of the screen step one is
cycle the door which you just manually
open and close so that make sure the
door switch functions correctly you're
going to release the emergency stop if
it's depressed but if it is the press it
would be in the in motion release you
twist to the right
it has arrows on the front of the button
and then you'll press reset to clear the
alarm the next step is to press the
power up button which is this blue
button right here on the control and
that will home all of the axes for you
with one button and then to clear this
screen you're going to press cancel to
exit out of that menu I mentioned that
you stopped during startup procedure
anytime your machine needs to be stopped
an emergency situation
do you not hesitate to use the e stop in
the machine this will stop all active
motion in the machine immediately
without delay release simply twist to
the right press reset and then you can
jog the machine back to a safe location
the hand jog wheel is used to manually
move the Machine around cycle start and
feet hold in the bottom left are used to
start the program when we're ready to
run feed hold is used to pause the
program it does not lose our current
position or reset the program simply
think of them as pause and start
in the upper left hand corner of the
keypad you have reset power up and
recover reset is used to clear any
alarms or to reset the program back to
the start
however we talked about earlier homes
all the axes it gets us ready when we're
ready to start up the Machine recover is
used if we've had a tool change fall or
maybe he stopped mid will change we can
simply press recover answer a few simple
yes-or-no questions and the Machine Lord
will recover itself and get it back
ready to run
f1 through f5 function keys just like on
your computer third function is assigned
based on the screen that we're on as you
can see here on the offset screen f1 and
f4 both have uses in this screen so
depending on what screen you're on
that'll set therefore they're using to
offset measure next tool full release
and part zero set are used for manually
setting tool offsets and work offsets
if your machine is equipped with a whips
program the probe system you won't be
using these programs will be setting
those rules and work on sets in a
different way we have our access
selection here when we want to manually
jog the machine we have X Y Z and then
on this particular machine we also have
a B and a seat when we select hand jog
we can select our axes to jog around
with my first hand job x-axis I can pick
the increment your available we have one
tenth one thousandth ow and one hundred
thousand I select ten thousand each each
pulse of the hand wheel will move in the
x-axis 10 thousandths of an inch
alright it's like $1,000 post each one
of the take months if I hold the x-axis
it will feed at the increment of the
lower number we have 100,000 one inch 10
inches and 100 inches a minute the jog
log button is the same as holding the
button but we don't actually have to
hold it so we can press jog log
take the axis of movement and we'll feed
at the feed rate we have selected simply
depress the dog log the turn on chip
forward chip stop and chip reverse will
turn our chip augur or chip conveyor on
or off in either a forward or reverse
motion the blue cross chip cord to start
the chip augur or chip conveyor chip
stop turns it off when the conveyor is
moving the door will be locked so if you
ever have a situation where you can't
figure out why the door won't open
verify that your father isn't left off
come on up cool it down on the
right-hand side of this section is used
for App equal this is programmable
coolant nozzle some machines is equipped
with that and in each pulse of the wheel
or excusing pulse of a button will move
the coolant özil up or down one position
ox coolant will turn on your through
spindle coolant if your machine is
equipped the override button was located
in the lower left-hand corner of the
control panel are used to override
programmed feed rates or spindle speeds
you can see there they have a hundred
percent then plus ten or minus 10
percent up or down simply press once for
each 10 crewmate 10 percent increment
100% just jumps right back to the
program feeding the handle feed when
depressed will allow us to increase the
bead rate or spindle speed by one
percent increment with the pulse wheel
simply press 100 percent jump back then
you can turn off by pressing handle feed
or handle speed again Ford stop and
reverse are used to start the start of
the spindle and forward or reverse from
the last program feed rate keep that in
mind the bottom row 5 25 50 100 percent
our rapid overrides 25% is recommended
by Haas we're proving out a new program
you may find 5% to be a little more
reasonable
one nice feature of the Haas control it
does feature a full alphanumeric keypad
this is featured across the entire
bottom of the control panel any input is
listed in the input line for you to
press enter or use under insert alter or
delete insert it into your program
cancel is basically backspace getting
the yellow icons simply press shift and
then the corresponding button to get
that symbol
the cursor in the center the control is
used to navigate around the menus for
example when we're on the offset page we
can use the cursor to move around
between the different highlighted text
boxes home is used to go to travel all
the way to the top of the screen
and will take us to the very bottom
available line H up and page down will
do exactly that
we have one page at a time in the upper
right hand portion of the control we
find our mode selections we have edit
memory MDI handle jog zoom return and
list program edit is used to edit our
g-code program we can use the cursor to
navigate around and then use the
functions insert alter delete undo as
well as the keypad to make any edits
necessary we press f1 we also get the
menu so we have save save as discard
changes we also get functions undo redo
cut copy and paste search we get find
and replace text then modify we can
remove or add line numbers reverse
positive native slides or verse X&Y
memory is a mode we go to when we want
to run our program when we have our
program selected we can select memory
good idea to hit reset make sure at the
top and then cycle start to run the
program inside of memory we get other
options single block will let us execute
each line of code with each press of a
cycle start simply press single block
and turn off graphics we'll pull up a 2d
image for us or our program to run in
they simply press cycle start to run the
graphics then we can use f2 to enable
zoom and positioning inside the screen
option stop
well stop and pause the program any time
it seeds in m01 in the program this will
allow you for open the door check the
part check the tool maybe clean some
chips off whatever you need to do to
turn it off simply turn the icon off and
then will ignore all in ones and run
continuous lock delete is used for when
you want to skip certain sections or
specific lines of code anytime you have
a forward slash on the front side of the
code or on the front side of the line
when blog delete is active it will
ignore that entire line of code when
it's off it will read the entire line
just as it normally worth MDI stands for
manual data input this is used for
probing sequences or maybe short
sequences of code that we just want to
type in we can also kind of cool it on
and off simply by pressing coolant like
handle scroll to allow us to use the
handle jog wheel to scroll through
programs or through menus ATTC forward
and ATC reverse are used to you manually
change the tools you can simply type T
and then whatever our tool number was
and maybe we went to number one and then
to ACC forward and the machine will
execute I still change to put that tool
and handle job we spoke about earlier
zero return is used to manually ohm the
axes or just for them to rapid Traverse
back to their home position you can
simply press zero return all which would
be very similar to pressing powerup
which we discussed origin and single we
can send axes back to their select a
single axis and move it back to its home
position palma g28
will rapidly traverse the exit back to
its home position it's a good idea to
use home g28
throughout the day rather than resetting
your home position every time you want
to go home this program
it's how we select the program we want
to run we press list program it'll pull
up the memory screen and will show all
the programs that are available in our
current machine currently we can scroll
down to the program that we're after and
select hit select program and that will
make our active program come on
if we wanted to run a different program
we could hit list program select a
different program select program then we
could go to memory and then continue to
run from there the left and right arrow
buttons on the screen I like to you
think of these as the forward and back
buttons on my web browser it simply take
me backwards or forwards through the
screens that I was just on race program
can be used to delete an existing
program for example if I wanted to
delete this program I can simply hit
enter
get a checkmark in the box erase program
so yes that's the one I confirm that's
the one I want to delete and the
programs the leader it's a little
program from a USB or network to go to
the list program we can air up to the
top of the list we select USB or the
network let me go down and we find the
file that we're after this is a program
i wanted i simply compress fq or copy
then i select where I want to copy the
file to I want to copy the memory and
then just inside a memory so simply
press enter and it loads the program
under the display section in the center
portion of the control we have program
position offset current commands alarms
diagnostic setting and help program
display is what automatically comes up
when we set memory this displays a the
program
resection of active codes active tool
information recurrent coolant level
override feed rate position and a small
timer to counter section overall a good
view gives you a lot of information the
position display has four different tabs
it shows our current position related to
our work offset under program this since
to go is active when we're running a
program and it tells us how far we have
to travel to complete the current motion
machine position is a machine is the
current state of where the machine is at
from its home position operator display
is the same as a digital readout that
many of you may be familiar from a
manual machine when you're in hand jog
and on position we can zero these axes
much like a digital readout the
instructions are on the screen we simply
press the access letter plus origin zero
axis I'll pick X origin and I can 0 you
can also set it to a current position
maybe you want to travel from where
you're currently at a certain distance
and not have to do the math so we could
say x 10.0 and then press enter and it
stores that value in that position it's
a handy tool all gives me all four
displays on the screen at once I like to
use this display when I'm proving out a
new program just because I can see all
the information that mapping the offset
display takes us to the tool and work
offset pages when we press offset we're
currently on the tool offset page so
this sees all the active through offset
we see it a note for spindle that tells
this tool 1 is currently in the spindle
we can see our link where link diameter
and diameter where my cursor to the
right we have a lot a indicator bar it
shows us where we're at there's quite a
few pages to the right here this is
where we can set up the total number
flutes on our tool so that our chip load
displays correctly actual
and a lot of the information that is
required for probing will get into this
a little deeper but it's all shown on
the offset you get to the work offset
you can simply press f4 use a shortcut
or arrow up to the top over and back
down to get to work this shows our
active work offset g54 etc X Y Z and on
this machine we have BNC available as
well
the current commands tab has a lot of
information behind it we press current
commands we have devices as a first
option mechanisms we can manually orient
the spindle or turn on the spindle break
on this one your machine may have other
options available then put air up we
also have a timer's page here this is
similar to what's available under the
program screen with a little bit more
information this is also where we can
set up a macro display macro variable
tab will get us to the display where we
can see all of our macros available this
is an option your machine may or may not
have macros available the active codes
tab is a little bit more detailed
version of what's available under the
program screen this shows us all the
active information in our machine ATM is
used for automatic tool management this
is used for setting up redundant tooling
in your machine you can set up some
logic to where the machine will
automatically tool change to a new tool
once one has it been expired if your
machine is equipped with a random tool
changer or high-speed tool changer
you'll have a tool table in the machine
and the control that lists what tool is
in one pocket plus I have a calculator
available under current commands and
down arrow and use a standard a milling
speed and feed calculator and then a
tapping calculator the alarms display
has a lot of information behind it we
press alarms we can see any active
alarms that are on the machine as my
e-stop was active I get the alarm number
and a brief description when no alarms
are active this display will remain in
messages
messages I can convey through the
program to the machine operator alarm
history keeps a log of all alarms in the
machine these are time-stamped and dated
so you can go back and search and see if
you've had some consistent alarms or
help to troubleshoot alarm viewer allows
me to look up a description of any alarm
number that I've seen on the machine or
if I just want to go and read what's
available I can down arrow and search
through or I can type in the alarm
number and then use the f1 search
function to find that along key history
shows all the keystroke history
available on the machine this goes back
several hundred keystrokes and they all
are time-stamped and dated I like to use
this in case I think I've got figured a
number I can simply go to this display
and verify what I actually typed in
under the Diagnostics key we get all the
Machine Diagnostics re-engages
show all the current available gauges
system will give us our system
information shows Miss machine serial
number software revision power on time
io is our IO monitor for all the machine
work on and keyboard IO as well
maintenance tab shows our loop cycles
many machines are going to be preset
from Haas with the correct increment or
the cycle times we can force an axis or
spindle lubrication by pressing f2 or f3
coolant refill is a machine Haas option
that automatically hooks the machine to
water and a coolant supply keep them in
the coolant level drop down software
update is a new feature that Haas is
working on that will allow them to
update the software remotely from
machines that are on the network under
the parameter
we have features here we can see what
features are available for our machine
and if they're purchased or available
for a tryout if your machine shows
tryout time available you can simply
highlight the correct line item you can
use the Enter key
turn the time on or off plus have
confrontation then an activation tab is
used when two machine has been purchased
this is a showroom machine so this has a
countdown timer once your machine has
been paid for you will get a permit
activation code that you'll come to this
screen and dinner it will permanently
unlock your machine if we press the
Settings button it'll bring up all the
Machine settings available we can scroll
through those using the cursor and
change any settings we need best that we
deem necessary we also have a search
function available so if we have a
setting that we're trying to find we
just don't remember the settings number
we can use the search function I was
looking for something related to SSB for
example I can type in SSB use the f1
search function machine will search and
find all the settings related to
assessing power up and over under the
network tab this is where I'm going to
set up my wired or wireless network
connections net share is used to connect
your machine to your internal network
stack this file us connect is an app
available for your mobile device allows
you to see the status of the machine
remote display will allow you to see the
machines control the actual control
display on your device away from the
machine rotary tab where many of you
will be where you'll set up a fourth or
fifth access rotary user positions can
be used to set specific settings related
to positioning second-home position
for this particular UMC can be set to
bring the spindle right to the door so
we'll change mid position maybe use if
you have a tall fixture you can set a
tool change position that forces the
spindle to go up position the table a
certain place in its environment
to allow a tool change user travel in it
can be used to set a travel in it for
any particular axes I wanted a set one I
can go into the user travel and I'm
physically jogged the access I want to
limit its travel to the location that I
want to live minutes to travel then I
can hit F to the storage current
position and that will set a soft limit
in the machine so not allow it to travel
beyond that point the alias codes tab is
for creating your own custom energy code
this is defined very thoroughly inside
the manual the help menu on your house
control is very thorough simply press
the help Display button and it will
bring up the help menu they have a table
of contents energy code lists
programming examples anything that's in
the manual is already loaded on the
control one of the great features is the
ability to use the f1 search function if
I here again and looking for something I
don't know where it is in the manual I
can use the search function to find it I
use an example of SSB earlier in
settings so if I search SSB I press f1
on the help menu it's going to pull up a
list of every place the SSB is discussed
inside of the manual I can simply
highlight the section that I'm looking
for press ENTER and it'll bring up the
description pencil will back out back me
back out into the main menu and I can
find what I'm looking for with the
sample programs that are available I can
even copy straight out of the help menu
pasted into my program change the
numbers and make it match my specific
example and save myself a lot of time
so use the spindle probe to set a work
offset I'm going to navigate first to
the Edit menu up to the top and over to
bps the stands for visual programming
system I'm gonna down arrow
I like probing right arrow then I'm
gonna select work offsets
these are all the types of features that
I can set my work offset from this
particular example I'm going to use vise
corner or right arrow and then I'm going
to use the instructions on the screen to
step through each function first line is
asking me what work offset do I want to
set I'm going to say gene 59 for this
example it's like 59 enter down arrow
it's gonna ask which corner am i setting
on the block for this one I'm gonna set
corner number one my lower left hand
corner x and y are both asked me what's
the incremental distance from that
corner how far over do I want to step
over this currently said it a half an
inch I'm gonna leave it with that set Z
is how far from where I position my
probe that I need to travel down to
actually probe the surface icon here
shows me where I need to position my
probe to start the cycle for this one it
shows me right over the corner that I'm
trying to send so I'm going to go to
hand jog jog the spindle directly over
the corner that I'm trying to say
this isn't something I'm measuring we're
setting I'm only eyeballing this
strictly directly over the corner
backing over my template I have a
position like the image have all my
value set let's simply press cycle start
to run the cycle this particular cycle
so to see off the top to face then it
sets X&Y work offsets once the cycle is
done hey the green light
show me it's done I go to my offset page
I can see the work offset that is set to
use the visual programming system to
generate g-code I'm going to navigate
first by hitting edit air up to the top
over to VPS down select bps right arrow
these are all the options that are
available for generating decode for this
example we're going to do circle contour
milling right arrow to enter the
template and it's simply I'm going to
use the prompts and fill in the blank
what work offset do I want to use both
tool number do I need this example we're
gonna use tool number one
what diameter is the tool 0.375 I need
rpm feed rate of the tool simply turn
the coolant on or off retrack million
above the part how deep is my finished
feature where is the position of the
feature
this particular one wants another
diameter hole feature so we'll say we're
milling a two inch circle it's going to
ask me if it's internal external
external feature and I fill it in all
the blanks at this point so to generate
the code are you press f4 it gives me a
few options I can insert this into my
clipboard and paste it into an existing
program and output to MDI or you can
create a brand new program that's create
a brand new program so I'm going to
press number three it's gonna ask me
where I want it I just want it in the
memory I'm just gonna ask me for a
program number a file name and a foul
coming press Enter now that program is
created I got a list program there's a
program I just created and hit select
program and I have my key
[Music]